[Music]
as a husband who loves this person did
you ever you know
want to like get out a length of pool
chain and go full corn pop on these
people
the answer is no no no but
there's some of these anyways
ugh what a shameless shill that guy is
he was once a comedian and talented
politics rotted his brain that of course
was joe biden sitting across from me
explaining he's totally comfortable with
his wife performing surgery or
prescribing medications
she's a doctor but biden didn't just sit
for an interview with an angry former
comedian to sue this wife's
status anxiety he also wanted to defend
his son yes hunter biden is under a
criminal federal investigation
the other hand he's a genius we have
great confidence in our son
i am not concerned about any accusations
but made against him
it's used to get to me i think it's kind
of
foul play but look it is what it is and
uh
he's a grown man he is the smartest man
i know
i mean i'm afraid of pure intellectual
capacity
um and uh and as long as he's good we're
good
can you reach across the aisle to people
who will be using
this as an attack on you
when it is such a personal attack
because it's about family
but if it benefits the country yes
it's about family yes it's about family
doing
business with foreign countries that
hate us in order to get rich
that part didn't come up in the
interview the whole thing was like this
and even for our compromised
filthy news media the level of shilling
for a politician
was a little nauseating today the biden
team took a zoom
press conference and only saved time for
five questions
the reporters were offended who knows
what they thought they were getting but
that is what they're getting
a reporter from the daily beast probably
the most dishonest site on the internet
asked this
hey guys there are tons of folks looking
to ask questions and since this is being
done once a week could we please go
longer or at least hold more frequent
briefings please
please we got you elected won't you talk
to us
oh it's pathetic